Ed stafford is a survivalist explorer
and adventurer,
an internationally acclaimed
motivational speaker and author who has
been described as Britain's most
intrepid hero since Scott of the
Antarctic.
He's experienced extremes all over the
world and is the Guinness World record
holding first man to walk the Amazon.
Ed splits his life between filming
around the world and spending time at
home in London.
He blogs about anything related to
adventure,
remote travel and health and fitness.
Ed Stafford,
frank,
you for very much for coming on under
the skin.
Absolute pleasure.
What fascinates me most about your work
as a sort of a survivalist or an
adventurer is the way that you talk
about the,
uh,
sort of conscious and spiritual
component of surviving in extreme
situations,
but in a way your background is
traditional in the sense that you're
from the military,
is straight into the skin then,
isn't it really?
Uh,
I,
I think so.
I mean,
I've always thought it was,
um,
I'm,
I'm in the world of adventure.
Have done it off the back of a military
career.
And yet,
for me,
the sort of the obvious parts of
adventure that crossing rivers,
climbing mountains,
sort of toughing it out,
don't,
don't really interest me as merchant the
psychological aspects.
Clearly I think,
um,
you know,
there is a very physical element in
everything I do,
but the whole thing since the military
onwards has been,
uh,
has been a bit of a spiritual journey.
And,
and it's just,
it's,
it's interesting for me how such a sort
of stereotypical blokey bloke's job has
ended up being actually one which has
been quite,
um,
quite okay.
Sort of spiritual journey.
Yeah.
That is fascinating.
That's perhaps what fascinates me most.
Was that something that it a
superficially seems to be about over
modes of masculinity such as toughness,
insurance,
survival optimally in your view,
comes down to our spirituality.
I think.
I think it's evolved at the most.
I think
when I started,
when I,
for example,
wanted to walk the length of the Amazon,
I think there was a lot of ego involved.
I think I really wanted to prove to the
world that I was super turf,
beat my chest and um,
do something that everyone was saying
was impossible.
And so,
um,
in fact that really annoyed me,
you know,
everyone said,
no,
you're going to die,
or they laughed at me or they didn't
think it was possible and I was just
like,
I'm just going to prove him wrong.
It was literally a two finger salute to,
to those sort of naysayers.
And I think,
um,
just because it started in quite a sort
of a macho way,
I suppose it's taken me by surprise,
the journey it's taken me on because
there's nothing macho about what I do is
the moment,
you know,
it,
I really don't need to prove anything to
anyone.
And again,
maybe this is just an age thing.
I'm 41 now.
So I think as you get older you don't
need to show off quite as much as he did
as a kid.
But um,
but,
um,
yeah,
certainly I think that what I'm doing
now is quite a,
it's quite meaningful and,
and I don't,
I don't know,
it,
it keeps me learning.
It keeps me in a position of being quite
humble as well.
When you were in the military,
my superficial and inexperienced
intuitive understanding of life in the
military is that a must be extremely
testing on you physically and mentally
and it must be a lot about making
individuals behave in a cohesive way and
respond well to all 40.
What was that like for you as an
individual?
What would you like for your mental
health at the time you spent in the
army?
And if I'm honest,
I don't think I,
um,
I took to the army at all.
Well I'm a joins because I wanted to
roll around in the burden throughout an
outdoor job and not sit behind a desk.
And,
and in that respect it's always correct,
but I never really.
There's a fear that I don't know whether
you understand when we even see a
military camp and all that barbwire
around the outside.
When I go into Cam,
I would get properly scared inside on
the left as a captain.
You shouldn't arguably be scared of the
campus if you're,
if you're,
if you're at that level.
Um,
and yet I did a,
it was a very disciplined environment.
It was a very strict environment and it
is one that is run on,
run on discipline and,
and,
um,
sort of regime.
And that wasn't me at all.
Um,
I might have taken a lot from the
military,
but I've always been quite a free spirit
and I've always liked the ability to do
what I want to do and get up in the
morning and I'd like to plan my own day
rather than,
you know,
for the next six months in advance has
been planned for you.
And so it was never really me.
Even in training at Santa Stowe was not
counting the days til I finished
training,
which the other recruits were.
I was counting the days to actually
could leave the military because I could
tell it wasn't really.
And yet it was something I almost did as
a of finishing school and all,
it's given me the skills I needed to do
what I'm doing now.
How did you flourish in an environment
that was so counter to the way you
wanted to be in the way you saw
yourself?
How did you,
because you obviously succeeded,
you've got to the rank of captain.
How many years were you in the military?
I was,
I was in for four years.
I didn't flourish if I'm honest.
Um,
I,
I feel like I've come into myself in
more recent years.
I'm in my early thirties rather than I'm
in my mid twenties.
Was,
was when I was in the military.
I remember telling my commanding officer
that I was gonna leave and he just
smiled and said,
yeah,
that's probably best,
isn't it?
I mean,
I literally,
I wasn't that good because I think,
I don't think I was into it,
you know,
I didn't have any interest in guns.
You know,
people go on Stag do's to Las Vegas and
she just leaves me cold.
I'm not interested in.
I did spend time in Afghanistan and the
other consultants,
they were,
um,
they couldn't wait to decommission the
weapons off the Afghans so they could go
into the middle of the,
into the middle of the desert and shoot
bazookas and stuff and that I just,
it's just not me at all.
And invariably you can bluff your case
for a little while and then after awhile
reached the rank of captain and the
thought,
this is about as senior as I want to go.
Bluff in my case,
I'm sure there's more to life as well.
With the battalion was going back to
Northern Ireland for two more years and
doing a really quite difficult
jobs to keep the soldiers motivated in
those sort of environments.
And so I decided it was time to leave.
What I personally,
I have tremendous respect for anybody
that can endure the military because
when I imagined myself in those kinds of
environments,
when you took right individuality in a,
a necessity respond to discipline.
That makes me feel really scared.
And the idea that you said about the
camp,
but I also have this sense that the
military,
you'd refer to it as a finishing school,
might be a place where greatness is
accessed in that you are tested as an
individual and like the whether or not
you can overcome and some mount certain
challenges.
Is that fair?
Is that what it was like in some ways in
retrospect?
Yeah.
A lot of the explorers around the world
have been in the military,
a runoff fines and you know,
all of the people who have made a name
for themselves.
And I think there is a reason for that.
I think it gave me a set of skills.
It gave me not just the physical skills
packing a work site and navigating those
sort of very obvious wounds,
but also it allowed me to think
flexibly,
bizarrely.
And you'd think that the military would
be quite,
um,
regimented with the way it thinks.
But they have got this thing called
mission command,
which essentially means if you know the
end state of what you're trying to
achieve.
So your commanding officers told you the
end state,
it's up to you as to how you do it and
um,
so it does allow a lot of flexibility,
conquer that area or get you to that
place,
attack that trench and it's up to you as
to whether you go,
you know,
through the stream,
straight up the middle or around the
forest and to recover or whatever it is.
So enjoyable.
That side of things.
I think when I came out,
when I started leading expeditions,
it was good to be able to know that I
could deal with situations and I can be
flexible.
So I did massively have to take my
military hat off in many respects
because,
you know,
a lot of the people that I was dealing
with were local people,
indigenous people from potentially third
world countries.
And you can't just go in there with your
sort of army hat on telling people what
to do or expecting things to run like
clockwork because it just,
you'll just end up exploding out of
sheer frustration.
So I had to completely take that off
trip,
chuck it all away quite frankly.
And,
and,
and I,
I'm happy to share that side of the
military,
you know,
as I go on year by year,
the military has less and less influence
over who I am today.
Definitely.
Did it,
did you,
while you were in the military question
the agenda and the objectives and this I
suppose that inherently what is within
military is,
uh,
the idea of force,
the idea of coercion,
the idea of control.
So there are a lot of things like on a,
on the level of our national identity,
we have to conceal about the role of the
military.
I'm not talking to individual soldiers
who is very,
very brave that anyone's prepared to put
himself through that kind of suffering
and I admire them,
but I'm talking about like the sort of
the political objectives of a military
organization,
for example in Northern Ireland.
And we'll just take one very complex
subject to that sort of stuff.
Trouble you.
Um,
I think,
um,
I never really believed in the Northern
Ireland occupation,
you know,
when we're out there.
And that was therefore difficult to put
on a and official face.
I was in charge of 30 soldiers.
They were looking to me to sort of,
um,
lead them through this,
through this experience of occupying a
another nation,
you know,
and okay,
we weren't fighting,
but you know,
we were unwanted there,
you know,
I was spit in the face.
Really?
You're kidding me.
You've had that happen.
Of course,
of course.
Every and every British army soldier
that's,
that's done any patrols in Northern
Ireland would have had that happen.
What?
But if you think about it,
if it was your back yard and suddenly
observation Qataris are going up and
people are spying on your houses and
stuff,
you'd be pretty outraged to.
And so I don't feel any negativity
towards anything.
No people that did that.
I didn't believe in what I was doing if
I didn't deliver.
So that must be.
I imagine it'd be hard enough if you,
if one had the mentality of queen and
country and the right of the British
Empire to Ra and occupy other territory.
So it would still be out if someone spit
in your face.
But if you sort of felt it was wrong
anyway,
did it just feel like the physical
representation of your own doubts?
I think.
I think if you sign up for some things
sometimes,
and this is really tricky,
isn't it?
Because when you,
because everyone.
Well I've developed over the course of
years and ability to tell whether
something's right or wrong by sort of
trusting my gut,
you know,
intuitively know whether you should be
doing something that didn't.
And Yeah,
I'd signed up to an organization which
it's got nothing to do with feelings or
intuition.
It was just literally this is your
orders and this is what you've got to
do.
And I kind of just,
I've got to admit,
I kind of just accepted that this is a
role that you've got to fulfill for the
next year or two years or whatever.
And once you've done it,
you can.
Then you can then break free and live
your life as you want to do it.
So I think I just sucked it up and got
on with it
at the time.
I wouldn't go back to it now.
I said,
what was it then?
So having been schooled,
hardened,
trained,
taught by the military,
or how was it that you found yourself
attracted to the seemingly impossible?
Uh,
I know that you were strongly advised
against trying to walk the Amazon not
least because it's made of water and
then new cheeses can do that,
that you know,
that you were at five today,
these were insurmountable challenges.
What,
what happened to you in a period from
leaving the military term,
taking on these great physical and
psychological trials?
What,
what made you think you could do it and
why did you want to do?
I think as much as the military,
it,
I didn't get on with it for the reasons
that I've explained what I did like is
being outdoors and what I did like his
physical challenges and,
and um,
and spending time next to nature,
I've got to be honest.
And so the first job I took when coming
out of the military was taking gap year
kids on,
um,
on trips into the rain forest.
So they were building a new visitor
center for National Park or something.
And you know,
18 to 24 year olds,
they're having a life changing
experience and I got the chance to use
the knife skills that come out with the
military,
have been able to take them into the
jungle safely.
There'd be sleeping in hammocks and
Washington rivers and maybe doing a
project which has got an ecological aim
or community based Damon.
And that was,
it was perfect as far as I was
concerned.
I was living at almost,
you know,
I've got paid next to nothing for that
job because it was charity work,
but it was using all the really nice
touchy feely part of it was taking the,
it was taking the army or expedition
knowledge and actually putting it to
good purpose.
So,
you know,
there were,
there was always a conservation or,
or community aim and mission to,
to each one of the expeditions.
And I flourished in that environment.
I loved it.
I did it for about eight or nine years
actually.
And um,
and really enjoyed it.
What did you learn during that?
Well,
it was more,
obviously I'm not ordering people around
paying volunteers coming on these trips.
And it was,
um,
it was more just about letting go of all
of the,
all of the worries and all of the fears
that have,
that I'd had building,
being in the military.
Suddenly people are all around me,
were having an amazing life changing
experiences.
And you know,
if when you pull people into the jungle
like that and everyone's wearing the
same grubby trousers and shirt and you
know,
there's,
there's no fashion,
there's no phones,
there's everything stripped away.
And yet people,
almost every single person on these
expeditions at the time would have said,
this has been the most amazing thing
I've ever done in my life because they
come together.
They bond,
they weren't really hard.
They're living in this almost like a
commune in the middle of it,
in the middle of the jungle.
And it,
I think it was extraordinarily
rewarding.
It taught people,
you know,
what life's about,
how to look after each other,
how to work as a team.
And it was,
it was a youth development charity as
well.
So it was all about these people who
probably didn't know anything about
life.
And this is the first time they've
properly traveled away from home,
but they've done it in quite a safe,
organized way because it's led by
someone like me who is ex military.
But um,
I don't know.
It almost.
Yeah.
Almost every single person that I'm in
contact with,
a lot of the volunteers that came on
those trips,
just,
it literally,
it changed their attitudes towards each
other,
change their attitudes towards nature,
and they've got a huge amount of it.
People began to feel connected when they
talk to each other and to nature and to
who they really are,
I suppose with what we ca.
What's implicit in that is that living
in a civilized culture disconnects you
from yourself.
One Star,
two star,
or we start to form attachments to
material objects to things that aren't
real.
Like the way that we envisage people
isn't investigated for when people are
put into an environment that is stripped
back,
the reason they feel so grateful,
so connected is because they discover
some kind of truth.
And I suppose the spirituality in
essence is about the discovery of truth
and the fact that the car.
But the truth is beautiful.
The truth is connection,
not alienation.
Last despair.
Yeah.
And I think you hit the nail on the head
by saying it's not really.
I wasn't adding anything.
I was just stripping stuff away.
So yeah,
all the nonsense,
all of the phones,
all of the distractions,
all of the,
you know,
things that will turn to when we're not
feeling good drugs,
cigarettes,
chocolate,
whatever it is.
There aren't any of those,
you know,
and everyone was having to deal with a
very raw version of each other.
And I think that was lovely for star and
you know,
back in the day people used to tell
stories didn't and you know,
we would light a fire in the evening and
cook on it and then sit around and chat
to each other.
There was nothing else to do.
And so you're looking up at the stars
you're contemplating.
And it was again,
a world stripped away of the nonsense,
I think.
Yeah.
Well,
his trip to have a nonsense means that
people go within themselves,
but I don't imagine it's just plain
sailing or sort of,
you know,
sort of a communal trumpton about people
go through a lot of English,
don't they?
I mean I filled a part of.
I'm very attracted to what you do.
I admire it very much,
but it's with myself.
There's quite a lot of fear in there.
If I think right,
you've got to go and live in the woods.
You're not going to have your phone.
You're not gonna have a lot.
There's a phrase,
isn't there?
We become prisoners of comfort.
I feel that I am in many ways a prisoner
of comfort that I have not tested
myself.
I used to do this thing and this seems
like a mad thing to tell her survival
explorer because it's so lightweight,
but like I went to,
went out with this woman who had an
amazing state in the grounds of the
estate was a well beautiful.
Well the east stinking marsh pond.
Right?
And I have to jump in it.
Right.
And when you jump in it,
it was really cold.
It was freezing.
Then when you got in there,
when I got in there,
I go there and I'd think well like that
my body is capable not only of
experiencing that cold but also capable
of making that noise and all the time
they are not experiencing that code on
making that noise.
I'm disconnected from the guy that can
handle that.
So I'm like bobbing about just on the
surface of who I am.
Never experiencing the truth of just as
me as an individual on a sort of an
anatomical,
physical and essential way.
So imagining that in that is a tiny
pipsqueak scrap of the thing that you're
in a right that you think.
I think.
I think you're right.
I mean there's A.
There's a movement at the moment I'm
with amongst disillusion people working
in London called going on a micro
adventure and people will literally sort
of five to nine I think is the
catchphrase.
They'll leave work at five.
They'll take a train out into the
countryside though,
run up a hill,
sleep on top of a hill in the morning,
go and jump in a river and then get it
back on the train and being for work the
next day and I think that's quite
indicative of the,
of,
of just people not being satisfied with
this kind of mundane life and they want
to eat really experienced life and
obviously it's uncomfortable sleeping on
the hill,
it's know bloody cold jumping into the
water and none of these things that are
actually conventionally good fun and yet
it somehow does press a reset button.
It somehow does enable them to go in the
next day to work with a smile on their
face and feeling like they've actually
done something and it's very difficult
to actually explain why they're doing
it.
But I'm certainly,
I feel there is more to life than just,
I don't know,
getting on the tube and going to work
and sitting at a desk.
I'm not interested in being a number
like that.
I want to experience as much of life as
possible.
So like in a way we can sort of build an
idea that urbanization,
industrial industrialization and the
technological society is a way of
turning people into kind of the fuel for
giant factory.
Your role just becomes to,
as a producer and as a consumer in many
cases more a consumer than a producer.
Your connection to nature and reality
has been severed.
You're on the tube,
but you're saying that these micro
adventures are examples of people have
this yearning for what's real.
And Are you saying that this year and
any something you always add that you
felt I don't want to do some job where
I'm basically in some version of prison
and I'm trying to.
I reckon I reckon feelings more
personally now,
I reckon feeling is more important than
than thought.
And I think we all get lost in our
heads.
You know,
we all anxieties,
fears,
all this sort of nonsense going on in
our heads all the time.
And I think what I'm talking about is
just experiences which sometimes aren't
logical.
Why am I going to go in jumping out
stream the.
It's having a very,
very visceral experience.
It's certainly shocking or your body
senses it's making you feel alive again,
and it's,
and it's very hard to describe
logically.
And I've got,
I've got some really,
really good aboriginal Australian
friends and um,
and they went toe to me,
is that,
in fact,
the first time I met this guy,
he's like,
um,
we sat in the car,
nobody sat in the room for about five
minutes and obviously thinking about
those things,
I know of two,
five minutes he went and will you shut
the fuck up?
Because there were so many thoughts
going around my brain.
And like from an aboriginal perspective,
they'll try and tell this story quite
shortly.
But he,
they believe that,
um,
you've got three brains,
the biggest brain being your,
your gut and your instincts.
The second biggest brain being your
heart and your emotions in the smallest
brain being the logical brain and the
word that they use to describe the
logical brain is called Nando.
Nando is also the word that they use to
describe a fishing net that was all
tangled beyond repair or fucked in their
words.
And that's the word they used to
describe the logical brain and they said
the reason that western people confused
live so much is that they live in this
logical brain and it,
it's a tool.
Everything is meant to start.
And the guy,
you know,
all of your,
everything that you do or the way you
live,
your life is all starts down here and
okay,
it gets filtered by your heart and your
emotions and then it Latin.
It gets filtered in the lesser manner by
your logic and your and your logical
brain.
But this for me immediately explained
it.
It just made everything click into
place.
He's like,
it's not that,
that's not going to place.
It has,
it's a filter on the way out.
But everything has to originate.
And you know,
all sorts of expressions.
We've got expressions in our,
in our own culture,
you know,
you follow your gut,
but they,
they really genuinely believe.
And I,
I have to admit,
I have taken on the same bullish.
I think everything should originate.
And I the thing you know,
to live your life in an urban society
where you're constantly watching the
clock and you're in time and stresses
and all this sort of stuff,
it's all in your head isn't.
And all they were doing was to try and
tell me,
and I did it because I was going to go
put myself on a desert island.
So I thought they will be good people to
speak to about this.
And they said,
the more you live in your head,
the more problems you will have.
The more anxieties and fears and doubts.
And they were absolutely right.
The more you can come from an
instinctual place,
it's all of that.
It just evaporates in and you can live
in,
you can,
you can have a decent time on the
island.
Paris,
great wisdom.
How did you go from being the man in a
car that's like baptist?
I shut the fuck up too because you're
thinking too loudly.
How did you.
What did you learn from them and how do
you do that?
And it's been a long journey.
I mean the Amazon was two and a half
years that time isolated completely.
I'm earned on the island was 60 days,
which is a long time in complete
isolation was 60 days in complete
isolation.
Well,
I'll be completely honest.
I was l twice and twice.
They sent in a because I had a satellite
phone to call in case there was twice.
They brought in course of antibiotics
but then left me again.
But other than what did you feel like in
the moments when someone drops off the
antibiotics?
He talked to me.
Hold me.
You would think.
I would think that I got angry at myself
immediately.
I called use the satellite phone.
I got angry that I was breaking this
sort of a rule that you'd say,
you know,
I was going to have 60 days in isolation
and you know,
why didn't you call?
What is that?
Well,
because I'm not a doctor.
I didn't know what was wrong.
I was like,
what were you experiencing?
Cramps and pains,
which I think the first one was trapped
when something so in a,
and yet I'd obviously got myself and
it's very difficult to describe.
I don't know whether you've spent
extended periods of time in isolation.
No,
may bucks.
Ten minutes.
I started free out,
but it's far from a,
from a spiritual perspective.
It was one of the most,
one of the biggest catalyst I think I've
ever experienced because there was
nowhere to hide.
It was,
um,
it was like a mirror to yourself,
but,
you know,
I couldn't distract myself in any way
because there was nobody else there that
it was almost like the enormity of just
being in my own presence was,
um,
was overwhelming enormity.
Okay.
I think it's again,
quite difficult to explain,
but,
um,
I think we all live our lives and I
certainly used to in a way where you
bounce off other people.
So I,
you know,
in this interview,
I'm constantly reading signals off year
in order to get an interpretation of how
I'm behaving,
you know,
uh,
the fact that the producer next to me,
it isn't,
you know,
jumping up and down.
It's like,
okay,
things are going okay so I can continue
to live my life in this way,
strip all of that feedback away so it's
just you certainly your sense of self is
like,
well,
who am I?
Because nobody's giving me any
reflective sense of who I am and almost
vomiting on the bees.
Genuinely.
I was almost sad because,
oh,
the concept of who I was just evaporated
and I was scared that she stole all the
hairs on the end of I thought,
who am I?
And then other people provide your
parameters if there's no feedback,
no bounce back.
Who are you?
I just had the image Ed of light that
the self being like a radiator radiant
radiate in our energy in imagery,
and if that secret,
no,
never gets bounced back.
It's limitless.
It's infinite.
Once I met this man in America is a
cowboy.
I think it was around the Co.
Yeah,
and he said once there's only so much
horizon a man can stand either.
If there's just endless horizon,
it's going on forever and no one's
telling You who you are and you start to
think as you were saying,
how am I?
So what happens next?
Okay,
so now I did.
I'd love to say that the penny dropped
on the island,
but it didn't at all.
It was afterwards.
But for you going from extreme anguish,
then someone's on that island.
It was,
it was a knife edge of,
of.
I was so filming a project for the
discovery channel.
It was,
I was also going through this sort of
isolation,
um,
well,
extreme effects of being put in sort of
solitary confinement.
Solitary confinement is a punishment in
a prison for a reason.
Well,
okay.
Again,
long story short,
I came off the island,
didn't have any sort of decompression
therapy or anything like that.
And then about a year later was meant to
be filming another series for,
for discovery.
And I couldn't get out of bed.
I was crying.
I was,
um,
my,
my courage.
It was through the floor.
And um,
again,
long story short,
but I went into therapy and I,
I,
I found out because he invariably,
when you do go through therapy,
get this sort of terminology for certain
things and what I,
the way I've lived my life they term as
a reflected sense of self.
But what they tried to engender with
emea was my own sense of self.
So united.
So you okay.
I'm not the concept of there being a
horizon being you can only take so merge
and again,
the isolation being so enormous.
It's only because I was,
I was,
I could only feel comfortable when I was
getting reflected sensitive self if you
have sense of self is coming from the
inside.
Because for example,
I had just started developing a moral
compass,
you know,
if I was to steal your pen and walk out
today,
it's not a big thing but I wouldn't do
it anymore because it won't feel good
about myself.
But it doesn't matter whether you're new
or whether like I don't.
I now live my life in a really honest
way.
And I think having to strip it back and
work out,
work out who I was was about what I
stand for as well.
So I won't steal off you and I won't
cheat and I won't lie.
And I think that's the only true way to
actually really know who you are as a
person.
It doesn't matter what anyone else knows
or understands or can find out or
anything like that.
And I now go,
okay,
I can sit here knowing who I am,
knowing that I've now emotionally mature
enough to I have a wife and have a kid
and stuff like that because I know who I
am.
Whereas if it was all based on how I
think I'm coming across to,
that becomes extraordinarily complicated
very quickly.
And I was in this chap and I would
honestly say that I walked the amazon so
that other people would say to me,
mate,
your fucking incredibly tough,
tough because they told me I would
investment in a way it's bonkers.
And so many people do live their life in
that way.
And it's just like,
you know,
coming from that true sense of self,
it really,
you really have to dig down deep to find
out who you are and what you do stand
for.
I think there's a thing that.
Yeah,
you're right.
I think there's a thing called
codependency,
you know,
like in 12 step circles,
meaning that your identity is a meshed
with other people's identity and
perception of you.
Now.
That thing you just described of like
needing the feedback and approval of
others.
I feel like we have a culture that's
fueled on that,
that everyone's running on.
Who am I?
What do I want?
Oh,
I am my phone,
I am my shoes,
I am my job.
I am not.
My wife thinks of me.
I'm just describing myself now.
For me,
my journey has been about having like
becoming an addict and haven't let go of
drugs.
I was addicted to then behaviors that I
was addicted to them.
Ways of treating people that,
you know,
all these things have had to be sort of
slowly let go of.
What you realize is those things are
doing a job for you.
They're holding you together.
So what?
I'm fascinated in the way that you have
physicalized and extreme eyes,
if that's a word,
like I like those,
that principle by,
you know,
like what say data.
Like you're saying the whole of the
island experience was.
Didn't bring about tiffany.
You came back from the island and sort
of had a mental breakdown.
Yeah,
I mean,
crikey.
I think being kind to myself,
I would have had to be pretty superhuman
person to do all of that self evaluation
and come to those sort of aha moments
and film program for discovery channel
and find food and water and all the
other things.
There was only so much I could do.
I mean it opened a can of worms,
but I didn't manage.
I didn't manage to come to any sort of
massive life conclusions.
I think I'm certainly not critical if
you decide if you made a real mess of
that time.
Yeah.
But I mean,
it's weird,
isn't it again,
because people who said to me,
you know that Ireland was conducive to
you being able to survive.
There was no better mistakes.
Food,
we've plentiful because you had coconuts
and stuff.
Why did you make such a meal of it and
yet you've clearly never been isolated,
have you?
And cranky some people manage it really
well.
You know,
there's ocean rowers who go longer than
I spent on the island and have absolute,
you know,
problem is with falling apart.
It must
be very strongly connected to purpose
and direction.
I reckon the only way,
luckily since obviously purely
speculative in my sense in except for
this yet another micro example once I to
do this stunt where it's a full
backwards off of a 30 foot feeling into
some crash mats.
Right.
And I was so scared of doing it that the
only way I could persuade myself to do
it was by focusing on the small details
of put your foot there.
Then put there and do tell him exactly
what the stunt man told me in that
moment with my religion,
like I do these things and that way that
the fear could be navigated by the
coordinates of instruction.
I've been offered.
So on that island,
the way you what?
What were you like?
I was thinking possibly the fact that
you act to find food and keep yourself
alive would have been in a sense,
structuring the experience,
giving you st hold onto.
In fact.
Yeah,
I think you're absolutely bang on and
actually that's I think the,
what I wear,
what I came to thInk afterwards is that
because I didn't have a,
a lateral g,
you know,
journey from a to b,
there wasn't anything to strive for.
It was literally your plankton and
Ireland and you've got to with yourself
and there is nobody,
there is no time pressure.
There is,
you know,
the no desperation to get food because
it's all around you.
And so.
And that was part of the problem.
It was just like,
this isn't about achieving anything.
This is about you just becoming
comfortable with yourself.
Can I ask you candidly what coping
mechanisms city developed?
BecauSe I know that like for me it'd be,
that'd be,
that'd be obsessive about food.
I think masturbation would become an
issue.
I think I would find things that were
like controlling my states of mind.
Were there things,
because you said he vomited.
I mean,
that was obviously very physicalized did
things like.
I know it's a very plain and roots
question,
so I saw on ebay masturbation,
but one of the things he did,
things like that become that,
or at least I can tell you that or did
that quickly become quite redundant?
Well,
let's tackle that one first.
No,
see the one that interests me and I
didn't.
I didn't masturbate once in the ocean
and so it didn't occur to me one.
I think when you're malnourished,
your testosterone goes down.
You aren't thinking in that way.
I don't know whether it's something to
do with times of famine.
People weren't procreating because there
wasn't enough food around so that it
doesn't affect your libido.
Definitely.
Although it would've been a good
distraction.
You're roy.
I just,
I kind of put it out of my brain as
well.
I don't know why,
but I,
you know,
you can imagine this.
I remember.
Okay.
Studying for my a levels,
for example,
I would have done quite a lot and you
can eat it.
You feel grabby,
don't you?
Have yOu been doing that all the time?
I didn't really want that to be the,
uh,
the focus of my,
of my paradise,
a man alone
with god now type for a while,
those coconuts together and this
seashell here
I do,
you know what I did because I was so
scared of spending time on my own and
spending time with myself.
I again,
this,
this is a really crude way of doing it,
very involved or uninvolved,
but I wouldn't do It today,
but I made my self so busy that I didn't
have time to sit with myself.
So for example,
I decided I'd build a shelter and I'd
literally say,
well,
okay,
I could get up in the morning and I make
myself a little cup of tea of on,
but I'm going to get,
allow 15 minutes for that and then I'm
going to go to work and I'm going to
spend two hours at work and then at mid
morning on a comeback and I have a
tiebreaker and I literally scheduled out
the day.
so I didn't have any time.
And reflectively.
I've definitely think that's because I
was so scared of those times when I was
just reflecting when I was just sitting
with myself.
So I,
I kept myself extraordinarily busy
to get around that.
So you want your survival technique,
it mentally busy.
What happened?
Yeah.
Excuse me.
When you did find yourself alone,
what is the,
what was the quality of the fear?
What the,
uh,
the fear in the light,
you know,
what did you think?
Oh,
I'm not a good enough person.
I made mistakes when I was a kid.
I hate that.
I hate most of what was sort of,
what were the frightening things that
happened in your mind?
Okay.
Again,
this is far from a sub story too,
and everybody's got their own story.
Everyone's got stuff that gives some
issues.
last year with a knife and familiar was
adoption.
Um,
I was a kid and um,
I didn't understand this for many years
and I got up to buy very,
very loving middle class family.
I got sent to a good school and I have
no,
this is not a sob story to however,
there's a theory that,
um,
why do you think you have to keep saying
it's not a sob story?
Because I'm not as.
I don't want to maple sympathy and
that's not what I'm telling him.
I'm telling it because it's,
I think because it's um,
it doesn't,
it kind of all doesn't make sense unless
you go,
well,
hang on.
Why?
Why were you insecure?
Why did you need to prove these things?
and personally I think that came from
adoption.
Does it?
Uh,
can you explain it quite briefly in the
photos?
It is a theory that a baby,
when it's born to move the,
the biggest trauma it could possibly
experience did the equivalent of death
is being separated from his mother
because it can't feed itself and it
can't do anything to separate those two
things.
On a very,
very core level,
you are experienced the trauma of death
and then your whole life Builds upon
that,
that insecurity of being abandoned
essentially.
So I had huge abandonment issues and
that would spill out and all sorts of
different ways,
um,
school and you know,
getting expelled for minor acts of
vandalism to in my twenties,
in the military,
you know,
drinking and getting into trouble with
plays and bits and bobs like that.
And I,
I just think of course every man's got,
you know,
testosterone and every young man spills
over and gets into trouble and I think
that just shows spirit.
But for me,
the deeper insecurity,
the reason I needed to go to the amazon,
the reason I needed to do something so
big is because my insecurity was,
was so deep.
I suppose I just genuinely,
you know,
again,
the whole concept of not really knowing
who you are and not knowing what you
stand for.
I'd do anything for me,
it's dare me to do anything.
I literally do anything.
There was no boundaries and you know,
people are,
you know,
everyone knows people like that.
There's just like,
they're scary because they will do
anything.
Absolutely.
Anything new.
I definitely fell into that category.
Sends you understand things like this.
And the reason I think I say it's not a
sob stories,
because once you understand your
history,
it doesn't matter anymore,
it's just a chapter in your life and I
wouldn't actually trade and any of that
for all the money in the world because
it's made me who I am today and I
wouldn't have achieved what I've
achieved in life,
probably if it stayed in the same phone
and been brought up in a very
conventional way.
So I'm really,
and let's face it,
it'd be a waste of energy to be anything
other than happy with everything that's
happened to us because it's happened,
you know,
but,
but therefore it's just a chapter in the
book.
It was probably a good book.
It's a,
it became,
it became your gift.
The wound became your gift,
the damage,
the damage of like,
as you said it using your words to read.
The worst thing that could have happened
to baby.
It can be separated from the mother that
happened to you.
And curiously,
your life's agenda becomes,
can I survive alone?
That's the question naked on island.
I don't think there's any doubt that was
some sort of,
um,
self so,
so fulfilled prophecy.
I,
yeah.
Luck and attempt to resolve the issue,
the drama of your personal metaphors.
You are,
I am abandoned.
Well,
if I'm abandoned I need to survive
alone.
Can I.
And then to do that in front of however
many $95 million people on discovery
channel as well.
I don't know.
It was so deep that I somehow needed
this is sometimes,
which I haven't really quite got to the
bottom of this way.
I need to do these things publicly as
well.
Anything,
you know,
I,
I fully understand that famous and it's
a folly quite frankly and you know,
and uh,
and not a purpose within it within
itself.
And yeah,
it's amazing.
I did want to do it on a stage,
you know,
I want,
I want to be.
Would you be able to see it as well?
It wasn't just an intern.
Right.
That's true.
I suppose a person who's got the skills
to survive and survive,
but if you interesting that you raised
the point that it was about community
and about connection and about possibly
about exhibition or demonstration and I
mean in a way perhaps all of us have the
same sort of need to be loved.
This needs to be connected and certainly
all of us have the need to somehow
resolve the drama of our circumstance.
That drama of our childhood.
Like I must become this,
I must solve there.
She does a another again,
it's a therapy sort of,
um,
okay terminology.
But,
um,
does this include developmental
immaturity where you don't self parent
yourself?
And I definitely think I fell into that
category so I would,
you know,
drive my car at absolute maximum speed
down the motorway because there was no
version of myself kicking in and we all
have different parts of our personality.
But the adult version of myself wouldn't
kick in again.
And this is not a terribly good idea.
Or you know,
when you've had however many pints in a
lot of people would go to,
you know,
I've had enough.
Now.
I'm going to go to bed and go home,
whereas that and that never kicked into
me.
And,
and apparently there is a psychological
term for it,
which is,
yeah,
and it's not far off from codependency,
but you know,
it's the same sort of thing which is
literally just living in this childlike
state thinking that,
you know,
you can still be abandoned thinking that
you need to almost be so volatile that
no one can ever reject you because you
are rejecting them or by your outrageous
behavior,
you know.
And um,
I think the thing that has enabled me in
recent years because I got married two
years ago and her little baby about six
months ago and I have no worries that
I'm going to be a great dad and a great
father.
You know,
I just don't.
I am,
I'm,
I'm doing that at the moment and don't
doubt myself.
But that's,
I think,
because I've come through this whole
journey because I genuinely,
I meditate every day and part of my
meditation is,
is literally,
it's called self parenting,
but it's literally holding my own hand
through life really rather than
neglecting the,
you know,
how most people go,
like british people especially,
they're like self love is quite a cringy
term isn't it?
You know,
americans might say a lot,
but british people,
they don't want to talk about self love,
you know,
they take the piss out of themselves,
they're far more comfortable putting
themselves down or taking the piss out
of themselves and they are loving
themselves and I've had to do it and it
sort of visualization when I meditate
each day and it's just like looking
after myself,
being kind to myself.
And that then enables me to stand and
they'll go,
rIght,
I've got my values,
I'm looking after myself and then I can
genuinely in life go look,
I'm not lying to an or not harming
anyone.
I mean a really good position to,
you know,
he loved my wife and look after my child
and that sort of stuff.
When did you start the meditation again?
It was a therapy thing.
I mean,
I was offered whatever the medication
was at the time,
I can't remember,
but at what point your life is by the
way as well.
And I couldn't continue filming for
discovery channel because I had
essentially a mini breakdown,
but a year after coming off the island
for 60 days,
done the island,
the islands of success.
You come back and then when you get back
to normal domestic life,
everything's sort of hits you.
What was that experienced?
What was happening in your mind and life
then?
I was in at the time a really,
really bad relationship.
So the,
um,
you know,
the first call mode at the end of the
Ireland experience was to my,
at the time,
um,
girlfriend and we had an argument and I
was just like,
I can't believe that she's having a go
at me 60 days.
And so that relationship,
I don't know,
it was,
um,
it was absolutely notes.
I came back and um,
I think with hindsight,
you know,
tv is,
it's a scary thing that you go to
discovery channel,
you go,
I'm going to put myself under the item
for 60 days.
And they said,
well,
could you survive like no knife?
Nothing.
And I was like,
I don't know.
And they go,
brilliant,
let's do it.
Because they want to embrace it from a
televisual perspective.
They want to make entertainment for
people.
And if I struggled that would be really
entertaining.
Nobody really went,
yeah,
but is this going to do any damage?
You know,
psychologically,
certainly let alone the sort of physical
thing or that thing.
Why dId you choose six days on an island
alone?
Because I think I was forever sort of
gravitating towards an experience where
I really genuinely had to know that I
could look after myself.
I think it wasn't abandoned that thing.
I think it was me needing to know that I
was capable of,
of,
of survIving on their own.
and I don't think that's the end state
in life.
You know,
everyone can be as independent and as
they like and have as many survival
skills as ray mears,
but that's not,
it doesn't make you a happy person does
it?
I mean,
I just needed to come through to the
state where I was confident enough in
myself as a person too.
Then,
you know,
open my heart and,
and,
and embrace the people around me.
But I think I need to do one first.
If you know,
she got back and you'd have a sort of
mental breakdown and you're like,
you have this argument with your then
partner for africans.
That relationship breaks up and you're
alone
longer than that.
But um,
I enjoy it.
That you liked being alone would be odd
for you after you've done 60 days on an
island to think that you're alone.
Proof.
I know people and you know,
I really,
you know,
the best times in life have always been
shared moments they've never been.
When I'm completely on my own,
I don't think I can pick a moment when
I've.
Okay.
Sometimes if we're on a run or
something,
but even that isn't.
I'm going to have your endorphins are
going through your mind,
but it's in a certain parameters whereby
you know you're going to come home and
again,
the people that you love and it.
But I think in general you choose to do
the big moments of your life with the
people that you love.
Wouldn't you choose to spend millennium
christmas,
new year's eve with you know,
your best mates or whatever,
and I think that's what life's about for
me.
Family,
friends,
that sort of stuff.
But you've got to get yourself right
first
to have a meaningful input to their
family and friends.
I think my book about 12 steps and the
12 steps themselves from which the book
is derived.
It's about how you go on a journey to be
able to be part of a community by
addressing these issues without going
around Ireland for 60 days.
But by going in yourself and knowing
that you're probably being motivated by
things that you don't understand and
that's why you have to drink and that's
why you have to take drugs and that's
why you have to gamble.
Or that's why you're shopping too much
or that's why you're in bad
relationships,
so that's why you're doing your job.
You don't like because you've never ever
asked yourself the question.
You've never stopped and done something
as transformative or ritualistic as
being alone.
I mean like the idea of isolation.
It's a religious idea,
isn't it?
That in a monastic cultures,
and I bet in them aboriginal cultures
that were they able to go?
Yeah,
we did sound a bit like that.
Anyway.
We're a 15 year old boys sloughing off
and talked to survive.
They do,
don't they?
They go walkabout and you know,
one of the absolute aboriginal
traditions is,
is to go off as a young man on your own
and spend extended periods of time in
the bush on your own and you know,
that is a part of how they evolve into a
man.
And I think that's no coincidence.
So either I think,
you know,
for me,
I didn't need to sit there without any
of the distractions.
Addictions are not anything in life that
distracts you from just being able to
sit with yourself.
And I think it's hugely important.
If you don't quite know who you are,
if you've always like,
people are so busy at work for example,
and then they come home and because
there is that time,
in theory,
my brain gets switched off now,
but that will be.
Or I could stop thinking about stuff,
but that would be a bit scary.
They'll have a glass of wine and it's
just,
I need either to be stupidly busy or to
numb my brain,
but the other bit,
you know,
that actually just sitting in
and feeling how I'm genuinely feeling.
That'S the scary bit.
Holding reality being in reality.
So who was it that during this time of
crisis suggested meditation to you and
how did you get into that?
It was,
um,
it was a neuro linguistic programming
lady who was operating in called malecon
who operated from a little little clinic
in knightsbridge I think at the time.
And um,
I didn't really get on with the neuro
linguistic programming,
but she goes,
look,
this,
this app is for cynics,
you know,
and it's just a,
it's called headspace.
Went by a guy who,
who used to come from bristol a thing.
And he's a sports science guy,
but he,
he had dodgy part of his life and he
went off and became a,
um,
of buddhist monk and spent a huge amount
of his time actually studying meditation
and I think it has,
I mean hezbollah has earned him millions
now.
It's,
it's big in New York.
it's,
it's as big a lot of countries all over
the world,
but it's,
it's the meditation without the justice
and the,
you know,
the chanting and singing had an.
And I needed it to be accessible at that
stage because if We rewind a few years I
was,
I was very ex military and so I would
have taken the mickey out of people who
told me that I'd be meditating daily,
you know,
now for 10 years ago I would have gone.
That's just ridiculous.
I just have a pint,
you know,
do believe in god.
I don't reAlly like the sort of
religious structure put around.
I believe in something bigger than me.
Then I suppose the,
my,
my belief is the,
the closest to it.
I think that I can describe it as the
guy or principle,
you know,
the concept of the earth acting like a
living organism and therefore there is
something positive happening that's
bigger than me that is taking things on
a,
on a positive journey that has an
interest in things going well and people
functioning together and operating as a,
as an,
as a cohesIve unit.
And I think for me that's not religion.
I think it's quite a crude way of people
trying to use the smallest brain,
the logical brain to actually put sort
of parameters on something that you
can't really talk about.
But it,
it's,
I believe in something bigger than him.
There is some sort of harmonious
connection that these aboriginal mentors
and tutors that you found and made use
of.
What is your understanding of what their
spirituality is based on?
Well,
very similar.
I mean it's the universe.
It's,
um,
I mean they believe that their ancestors
are still around,
which I think sometimes the way it was
described to me is that your,
if your life is like if you were a jug
of water and you put it in one drop of
water falls out of the jug of water back
into another job at the bottom,
your life,
you feel like you're an individual
entity while you're that drop of water,
but you're just coming from,
uh,
the,
the sort of a source and you're going
straight by two and,
and,
and I think that's how they feel.
I mean,
I certainly know that jeremy and my
aboriginal friends,
they,
they talk about communicating with the
ancestors and they,
they,
um,
and they,
they walk in,
they have a foot in,
in more than one world.
And um,
and I think they believe in the
universe.
I think they believe in the positive
forces of the planet.
They don't over complicate it.
I think that that's because they don't
make it cerebral.
Don't use that.
What's that tangled mind called again?
It nando nando parrado.
There's a word of the day.
I'm like,
yeah,
we have a culture that lives in Peru
minds here.
Since you've learned all these skills,
does go in and being isolated or
comparable survival programs.
I don't know.
Obviously you continue to make these
very successful programs at these as
important as any other bit of kit or a
purse orange personal ability to
physically ensure these knowledge of
spirit and mind.
It's the most powerful to be able to.
I've got as as I would have.
I used to say the mind,
but it's not,
isn't it?
It's it.
It's greater than that.
It is the ability to control my state.
I think.
Wow.
You know,
I've,
I've definitely spent days and days and
days running around like a headless
chicken in survival situations,
making a meal of things,
but the time when you stop and compose
yourself and meditate that that's when
it starts going well.
So this is one thing thAt people that
are not surviving in extreme conditions
can learn because we are all surviving
on the,
on the mountains and terrains and
tundras of the inner space of the inner
life.
And we have to find a way of reflecting
somehow finding an inner tree,
an inner connection where we can find
repos and like,
you know,
I agree with what you've said about sort
of conventional religion that I believe
a lot of people get to access,
get to contact,
get to connection through conventional
religion.
But I believe that unless we have this
point of my struggle in my own life is
being able to find a point of access
like that and len maintain it because I
get distracted away from it if I get
frightened or if I get full of desire,
like it very hard to keep the
connection.
So I suppose it's fascinating when
someone distills it as you have done
into obvious.
Certainly not obvious.
I'm sort of modern.
I wanna say epic survival conditions,
you know,
if I can survive in this extreme.
Why?
I mean it's a slightly comical setting
really.
I mean,
I'm not in a survival situation,
I'm being dropped off by a tv crew in an
area where they know there's gonna be
some water and there's going to be,
and you're making an entertaining show
and the parameters are survival.
Yes,
I've got a lot of fire without matches
or a lighter,
yes,
I've got to find food,
but it is essentially a little snapshot
of life.
It's just life into glorious technicolor
and the fact that you have,
you've got to do all of those
components,
but I'm still stressed about will I get
the right footage to make the program
run
by worrying about whether I'm going to
pay next month's mortgage.
You know,
all the normal stuff was still there.
And therefore I think with the added
component of,
because obviously directing film,
everything myself with that component
and surviving,
it's huge control freak,
a massive control freak.
I certainly have been,
but um,
but I think,
I think yeah,
therefore meditation's really necessary.
otherwise I'd just tie myself in knots
all the time and it would all become too
overwhelming.
Would you be able to do the sustained
periods of isolation or even separation
now that you are a father and husband?
I've got a new show started filming in
january,
so I'm going to have to do mate that's
actually got a another show,
which I think they're going to
commission.
I'm not sure.
I'm not Allowed to say it involves my
family involved In both of them
actually,
which could be very.
That is amazing.
I really hope that gets made because one
of the things I think my fantasies
version of this is it must be so amazing
to know that it's society falls apart on
sometimes it feels like it might or even
the issue that you'd be out guy,
right?
It's okay,
we're going here,
we're going to do this,
this,
and that.
Must be amazing.
Yeah.
No,
I actually quite,
um,
I get,
I could do gain a little confidence that
I have known that confidence of being
able to go into the word,
take two bits of work together and be
able to make a fire.
That's a cool thIng.
I used to say the mickey.
So much of sort of geeks who watch star
trek and make fire by friction and used
to take the,
yeah,
take the piss out of them.
But um,
having gone through that and I'm in an
mls cynical person now,
I think it's a really nice wholesome,
organic skill.
So yeah,
It's almost like it would be a lovely
thing.
I'd love to know that.
I'd love to be to know that this is what
you need to survive because I feel like
possibly the sense of abandoned and
vulnerability that you described in your
own personal drama.
Most of us know our life is held
together by the power of other people
were like,
you know,
we're,
we need the house.
We need the clothes.
We need to say we need the media.
We need to advertise and we need the
comments.
We need the banks.
We can't confront the banks.
Bring down the bloody government will be
dead in 10 minutes because there's no
one can see in the american survivalist
movement.
The sheriff that night.
That is a sense of we want to be
independent.
We want to live tribally wanting to be
connected to nature in an hour like
that.
So that's the impetus,
but there's no language to do it and
there's no culture to do it.
And there's certainly no way of a
correlate in a or conflate in the fact
that it is a spiritual as well as
physical endeavor to be able to survive
in the world.
Yeah,
I think you hit the nail on the head and
think that's why my shows are successful
is because people want to vicariously
live in this world where they don't need
a bank there.
They don't have to go to the supermarket
in order to buy the food.
They want to be able to do it for
themselves.
And yet you're right,
there are no,
you can't,
you can't achieve that in this world.
You can't go off the grid really.
And the uk is it.
And I mean,
it's incredibly difficult to do so all
sorts of alternative cultures,
um,
think that they can survive without
money.
And certainly in the uk,
you know,
they can't
do that.
We're owned.
And in fact,
you also feel that if you try to do it,
forces would step in and prevent it.
Well,
the word,
I mean travel is obviously a looked down
upon and by a huge number of parts of
society aren't they?
Because you know,
they're not contributing to the state,
but we've got around culture,
we don't want to do this and making
their own choices and they don't want to
be a part of the mainstream.
And I think inherently a lot of people
have a bit of that in them anyway.
Those of us that don't have this
monumental will to survive an ambition
that you have expressed and six,
uh,
and uh,
achieved such success for what do,
what can we do to access and learn from
your trials and your journeys?
What would you suggest?
Even someone like me,
I mean my mate matt,
who's such a fan,
I'm a great fan of yours.
You a great hero of his.
He's like staying or like we want to do
campaign.
He's going definitely in some suspended
10 in a private word in essex this
weekend,
friday,
saturday,
and sunday.
And I'm debating whether or not to go
with him.
I mentioned it to my wife and she said,
yeah,
you should go.
You should go to bloody out.
I think like,
uh,
but like,
you know,
like easy that we should say,
right.
Some of my life has got to be like that
cold plunge in the pond moment where
you're hit with the reality of what life
is.
Would you suggest that sort of thing.
I think.
I think it's a really good idea to sort
of structure a bit of that into your
life.
Whether that's,
you know,
going,
walking in the peak district at the
weekend or wherever it is getting out of
london.
It's really difficult.
I think you can do it in london,
but it's really difficult to step out of
that heady space when you were in
london.
There's just so much energy with the
concentration of people,
but it might be a bit like that
aboriginal man san shut the fuck up.
It might be like that on him.
There's times 12 million winning
mentally.
Imagine all of the,
all of the energy.
And I hadn't said a word in that car and
yet he,
he just said,
I just cannot think with all that noise
going on in your head a bit.
Bloody jed.
I bet.
And it is a bit,
but It was quite cool as well.
It's welcome.
I think you do.
Most of us need to get out in order to
get that clarity of thought or to just
stop thinking.
And I think london confuses it or,
or very dense populations do confuse it.
Yeah.
So make space for yourself in some way,
whether it's sort of like a walk in to
pick some way of interacting with nature
in a very,
in a very literal way.
What about,
what do you thInk of this quote?
I think about it sometimes chesterton
said to the truly adventurous man would
it likes an interest?
And I'm not saying this as a dick with
a,
uh,
you know,
Instead of trekking across planes and
climbing mountains would simply jump
over these next door neighbors fence,
meanIng I suppose that adventure is
potentially all around us and what we're
bound by in a sense,
he's convention and we all live in
restricted space that you think that,
that,
that what you have learned as a literal
survivalist has had so many are evident
spiritual connotations and it's driven
you in the direction of the spirit.
That there are ways of crossing
boundaries that these techniques could
be applied to the way that we.
Are you curious about the way this could
affect societies,
what you've learned?
I think for me,
yeah,
I would agree with that in the fact that
I don't,
I don't feel that need to go and climb a
mountain or,
or,
um,
you know,
conquer something that hasn't been
achieved before as much anymore.
I think everyone needs meaning in their
life obviously.
and you know,
from having a baby recently as well,
that suddenly it just changes your
perspective on life.
You're not the center of the world
anymore.
Something really meaningful that yes,
okay,
it's a bit of a cliche and everyone says
that your life changes when you have a
baby,
but for me it has all of the stuff that
I still do and I'm not going to stop
going on.
Adventures feels like it has gotten
meaning because you know,
again,
there's an analogy that our is like or
relationship is like ships in the
harbor.
It's like built in a harbor and it's
safe in the harbor,
but you don't build a ship to stay in
their heart,
but it has to go out and it has to go on
journeys and it has to come back again
and I think it's all part and parcel of
the same thing.
yes,
it's good to go away and adventures.
Yes,
it's good to go and have experiences
outside of the nucleus of the family,
but invariably you're going to come back
and it makes going on those journeys or
the more meaningful because you've got
something wholesome and meaningful to
come back to you.
I think before that,
that's why it's called relationship.
You're meant to go on a voyage.
Weren't meant to be a punk,
but basically was,
wow.
So I think I want to,
I'm going to go and do this campaign.
We can think what I want to do.
Some,
learn some surviving things off you will
perhaps.
What should we.
Do we do it.
Is there some way you can think of
format in that alternative into anything
like,
I mean,
not necessarily for television but
possibly for television,
but like I just like feel like what
would you
eclipse suggest?
It wouldn't be a difficult thing to,
to set up a survival scenario where we
could go in and teach you if he wants to
as well.
It will be all over it.
Some survival stuff and then uh,
and then set he to It.
Um,
whether that's as a two or individually
on your own If you want to do experience
the isolation,
but as well.
But I really do.
Yeah,
I'd love to do wow
asset real good.
Clear.
And is there anything and just to return
again.
So it was a simple thing.
People listen to this podcast to learn
things in a later week here.
And you have been absolutely fantastic.
I want to do this because then like the
whole time I'm doing it,
I'm thinking this is all information.
This is amazing information.
I need this information to other.
He's actually actually matt morgan is
actually outside standing in the
corridor or looking for a nordic.
Actually come in,
come in,
come in.
that'd be so silly.
It's so under the skin.
And listeners,
if you listen to the radio show that I
also do.
You will have heard of matt morgan.
We're going to wrap up the show soon.
But matt would you.
He can't even get in the bloody studio.
It's elevated stuff.
Alright.
So matt morgan and ed's come and share
my microphone.
I don't when you bought the ring because
it will.
Yeah,
that's it.
Let's not try and pretend that we're
cool in front of it.
Now I told you I've already told it that
we're planning to do that.
Whether you are definitely the campaign.
the other thing is you're he.
Well one night.
Yeah.
Well possibly one night.
Is there any effort like whipping edge
been absolutely amazing.
And talking about like last,
this was the,
would be the podcast I would most
recommend that you listen to.
I think you'll,
I think you'll love it.
What,
what sort of trials and what sort of
techniques and tips would you suggest
that people listening to this now should
try in our own lives?
That without,
as I was saying,
being a monument and adventure?
Well,
I mean for me the thing that's helped me
and I do use it into over situations
and,
and outside is what we've already talked
about,
but that's meditation and you know,
the app that I spoke about,
the headspace,
um,
you know,
use your cultural collateral 10 minutes
20 pence with promoting genuinely don't
start our own ones that every day we're
let,
okay,
let's start with taking that time and
get him as a guest to have some
perspective over being wrapped up in
your own,
in your own life and being super
involved in your own little stories.
It's just stepping one step Back and be
able to have a bit of perspective and
clarity.
And that's helped me at home in
relationship since verbal situations
that across the board,
I just imagine it must be a phenomenal
lesson to know that you can survive,
that you can survive emotionally,
that you can survive spiritually,
that you can survive physically and
like,
and the importance that you've placed on
the spiritual component of that.
And I say I wasn't pushing it in that
direction as being not much.
It doesn't shut up about that.
Can we talk about stuff that I know
something about so I can complete in
this chat and.
Yeah.
So I think it's fantastic match.
You want to ask question and as you're
here in 87 bivy bags,
right?
Yeah.
If I'm.
Because I'm going tomorrow.
Yeah.
Okay.
is thEre any,
do they keep you any warmer in the tent
or is it just like there instead of
attending in a tent you don't need.
You don't even know if it's going to
told you that it was a t.
Skin tent has got an inner and an outer.
Yeah.
Okay.
But if you want to sleep outside just in
the baby bag,
then that's an option.
I'd go for like,
um,
polyester woven,
got full gortex because you could get a
bit sweaty and it's getting very real.
Now,
the last word for eight after all that
fantastic with said it before,
you get a bit sweaty after talking about
the true nature of man,
access to the infinite that we are trope
of war are traveling between jogs.
We're connected to the source and we're
connected to the force with ed stafford.
Thank you.
It'S been a tremendous education.
I'm going to take you up on those.
Survival offers a really ambiguous and
offers.
Ha ha.
Thank you very much.
You've been liStening to under the skin
tears.
This show was sponsored by my book
recovery,
which is available now.
You can order it on amazon.
You can also get the audio book,
which is terrific.
Check it out.
The things we've been talking about in
this show have a spiritual and mental
component and I may not be an access and
surviving out in the world or even in a
car on my own,
but I do know how to deal with your own
madness closer.
Come see me on rebIrth to her for a bit
of fun and a bit of escape birmingham on
the 5th of December,
lester on the 6th of December.
Brixton on the 19th of December.
I guarantee you we will have fun.
Go a russell brand.com
for tickets.
If you like the show,
please subscribe and review it on itunes
or wherever you get your podcasts.
Lots of love to all of you.
Thanks for listening.